[Music]
what is
up stickies welcome to stick to football
live if you're watching in the bleacher
report app and you better be
if you're not hopefully you're enjoying
the podcast version wherever you get
your shows today we're gonna break down
the nfc
north draft classes and there is some
controversy there with the green bay
packers
obviously we're gonna have some fun with
it matt mello and connor
rogers do not forget you can leave your
draft on draft comments
right here in the bleach report app just
type your type type right there in the
comment section below hit that little
fire button if you like it connor
and we will answer some of your
questions at the end of today's lovely
lovely program i'm excited to get into
the nfc north because
all these teams trying to catch my san
francisco 49ers don't think any of them
can do it spoiler alert
but it's going to be fun and these are
some really good fan bases i'm
eager but also nervous to talk about how
they did in the draft
and one of the more improved divisions
as a whole guys when we look at this not
across the board
but i'm looking at two teams in this
division that really came out on top in
this draft
yeah let's start with maybe a team that
didn't
come out on top i don't know if you guys
loved their draft
i did not and yes that was a pun i get
points for that the green bay packers
they won this division last year
only to get smacked right in the teeth
twice by the san francisco 49ers once in
the nfc championship game
yes i'm taking all i can get they trade
up to select jordan love in round one
mellow your grade and your thoughts on
the cheeseheads
man i'm giving this thing two f's i i
don't think one f
will suffice when you look at the green
bay packers in their draft class
i don't hate the players that they took
but what are you doing
you went 13-3 last year you should be
trying to make a push for the super bowl
you have a very small window here with
aaron rodgers probably has three four
years left
uh or so we thought before the jordan
love pick but you have an opportunity to
push this team forward
and make some splash plays instead
you're trying to rebuild an
offense that was already pretty damn
good you have a historic
receiver draft class and you didn't take
any of them i feel like the biggest need
on this green bay packers team
was a receiver and they had a couple
really good options
there in the first round and again in
the second instead you take a
quarterback who's gonna sit on your
bench
probably for three years for a minute
you take a running back who's not even
gonna be your number one running back
and then you take a fullback like i love
fullbacks but what the hell is going on
in green bay
i feel really bad for the fan base i
feel bad for the players in the locker
room
i think your front office failed you
know i'm going two f's here
i don't know if you can go any lower
than that i'm sure packers fans are
tired of hearing everybody just laugh or
mock this draft but i'm with you here
mello it was an
f for me i think this might be the only
f i'm going to give out
through through all these weeks of
grades we'll see but i look at it
i don't understand the strategy of it i
thought jordan love was a good
developmental quarterback that i'm okay
with i get it
he was your guy but you're not this team
that needs to hit the reset button
you're a team one of a few teams they
need to put your foot on the gas
and go and say hey we were really good
last year we had a disappointing end to
our season in the playoffs but we felt
like we were really close to a super
bowl
let's retool let's add a couple impact
guys
and i just don't think they did that
here they missed the opportunity to do
that in round one
you look at round two i like aj dillon i
don't think he's the right fit for the
packers though in terms of something
they needed aaron jones
is a phenomenal running back whether
they pay him or not you didn't need to
take a running back this early
right now when you look at d'aguara i
thought he was somebody that was going
to go in the fifth sixth or seventh
round of this draft it felt like they
took him a few rounds early a full
day early i just don't know how much
better they got so when i look at green
bay
and then i look at the rest of this
division and we're going to talk about
it
it felt like the other teams did a much
better job and now you've created
a really interesting scenario with aaron
rodgers that
i don't think he's going to take it out
on jordan love but i do think it'll
cause friction between him and the head
coach who seemed very happy to get a new
quarterback
him in the front office how are things
going to look now his final year
final two years with this franchise and
yeah you have davonte adams we like alan
lazard
you nailed it mello they didn't take one
of these wide receivers in a historic
wide receiver draft so it's been a while
since they've done right by aaron
rodgers
and man this was just not it at all
yeah i'll jump into it i give it an f as
well i think that's the the easy grade
for this
across the board the thing for me is
like you lost the nfc championship game
37 to 20 and i feel like the
niners held back they held something
back knowing okay we're going to super
bowl we don't want to show everything
we don't want the chiefs to know all the
tricks in the toolbox
they held back what did you do in this
draft that closes a 17 point gap
with the niners it's not like you have
someone coming back from injury where
you go
all right we get him back next year we
got the niners number
you did nothing and your first round
pick you i like jordan love and i even
like the move you have a 36 year old
quarterback
you got to think about the future i
didn't think you needed to trade up to
get him
who was jumping you to get jordan love
at this point and then they come back in
round two
are you like is this you want to be the
tennessee titans matt lafleur
your offense wasn't good there and i
understand you had derek henry he is a
unicorn that cannot be replicated he's
not a clydesdale you can't just go find
another one
aj dillon i did not think had any
business being drafted in the second
round i know he turned it on late
in 2019. i think he is a plotter man i
do not
see the lateral quickness the agility
that won't work in the nfl if you're
watching this show and in the bleacher
report app
i did not understand any of the moves
that this team made after
what was such a great off season into
the 2019 offseason they go get the smith
brothers of pass rushers
a developmental guy and rashaan gary who
has a huge ceiling
as an overall athlete loved what they
did 2019.
this off season comes around and it's
like did you all forget that you want to
throw the ball in 2020
no one runs the ball that's not how you
win games i think they're trying to
build that 49ers type
offense but you're not going to do that
with aj dylan i really don't
i like the player i don't like the fit i
don't have a problem with aj dylan i
think in a lot of offenses
he can come in and contribute i just
don't know
at least in 2020 i don't think the
packers offense is that offense maybe in
2021
they are the tennessee titans and they
go power well let's talk about the team
that will be
nipping at their heels in this division
the minnesota vikings who
they give kirk cousins the big extension
they trade stefan diggs to the buffalo
bills that was the big move that they
made
but what they did in the draft guys what
did you think
mello with your grade i love what the
vikings did i think this is one of the
best
drafts we've seen and the way that they
were able to work the board too
i feel like they got the two players
that they wanted to target in the first
round
and they were able to move back down and
get them and i love stephon
diggs i thought that was an a-plus move
by the bills
but i think it's also an a-plus move by
the vikings i like justin jefferson
more than i like a veteran in stefan
diggs now you get jefferson
on that four-year rookie contract you're
probably going to pick up his fifth deal
and i love what they were able to add
late cam dancer i know he ran the weird
40 and the pro day and
everything but the tape is good watch
the lsu tape
the tape is good you can find what a
player can do very well there
and then also adding a linebacker like
troy dye i really like what this defense
did
matt you mentioned that the green bay
packers will have the vikings nipping at
their heels
i don't think so i think the vikings can
run away with this division
with the draft class that they've had
and another year in this system of
running the football and
and doing what they need to do what's
your great mellow i'm going a plus here
for the vikings there we go i'll hand
out a couple of them i don't know if
it's graded on a curve or not but i
really love
what the vikings did there's so many
draft picks through here not just the
top two first round guys they really had
a lot of good draft picks
there's no doubt about that rick
spielman did a phenomenal job whether it
was acquiring more picks making the most
of them
we looked at two players that they moved
on from this off-season guys and xavier
rhodes who simply could not run anymore
last year
and stefan diggs where there was rumors
circulating around him for what felt
like a year or two
and they go in the first round and they
get two guys that could step in right
away
at those positions i thought jeff
gladney was the second best cornerback
in this class he's sticky he's tough
he's nasty i mean just go back and watch
him against denzel mims that's one of
the better prospect matchups
from this draft class and then you look
at this guy right here and justin
jefferson
he's going to come in and produce right
away across from adam thielen with kirk
cousins i think jefferson has
great catch radius he offers good catch
and run ability he was tough in the red
zone
a lot of people are sitting there and
saying well some of his production or a
lot of his production came from the slot
who cares he's going to produce from the
slot at the next level as well and he's
going to produce
on the outside i thought the vikings did
such a good job
by getting those guys in the first round
and then you look at someone like ezra
cleveland who i'm not even a believer in
even if he doesn't hit they rebounded
really nicely after that cam danceler
was gonna be one of your corners on the
outside as a starter eventually
this gives you an opportunity to move
gladney around whether you want to play
him in the slot or whether you want them
outside
now you have a lot of corners with
versatility and mellow you bring up troy
dye that's one of my favorite value
picks of this entire draft he was a
linebacker that went healthy
good athleticism in the middle of the
field can run and cover can stop the run
a good leader the vikings
just did so many good things across the
board in this class and addressed so
many areas of need
with high value players sure was a
little lucky justin jefferson had no
business falling into their lap
sometimes it's good to be lucky guys
this draft was an a
yeah 15 picks a lot not just what they
did in the first two
with the first two picks in round one
but that is where i want to start as
well i have to give them an a
no way do we think justin jefferson
would fall here this was a team that was
maybe brandon ayook maybe denzel mims
maybe they reach
for that fifth wide receiver off the
board jalen rieger going to the eagles
allows jefferson to fall to a perfect
landing spot for him i think he's going
to give them a lot of what stefan diggs
especially
in that yards after catch department but
they got two
tough physical corners and jeff gladney
and cameron dantzler
i love the value there and i know during
the draft weekend when they took ezra
cleveland i said
i don't like this spot for him i think
he's around like 100. he's my hundredth
player on the board
i like the fit here because he's not
going to be pressed into action so i
want to recant
what i said friday night of the draft
because you have time to digest things
and what they did with brian o'neill i
think that's the framework for what
you're going to do with ezra cleveland
brian o'neill is one of the best right
tackles in football
right now he needed time to develop and
i believe that's what they'll do with
ezra cleveland they'll get riley reef
off the field
thank the lord maybe move him back into
guard where he actually belongs
but i'm giving them an a for the what
they did to get better right away
but also the foresight with some
developmental guys and i'll say one more
thing here
and you guys i feel like would agree
with this compared to where we all had
them
i think kenny willis has a chance if he
could stay healthy to be the best
seventh-round pick in this draft
yeah absolutely we are all big believers
kenny the athleticism the work ethic is
absolutely there right don't forget
you'll leave your draft on draft
questions right here in the bleacher
report app
right in that little comment section
below me where my fingers are going
just type your questions in there we
will answer them at the end of the show
but i look like when i type when you
type that it's like matt bowen typing
i'm just breaking my keyboard
today's show is sponsored by playstation
home of
ncaa football 2010
the last college football game the ncaa
felt they could put out before
people started asking questions so dust
off denard robinson on the cover and
play ncaa
football 14 where you can play as a
legally
unpaid jameis winston and lead the
seminals to the 2014 national
championship game
a matchup mello most people remember as
a duel
between current friendship kickers cody
parkey and roberto aguayo
instead of blaze 14 the graphics they're
okay thank you playstation for
supporting
stick football and by the way uh you can
download updated rosters and mellow will
whip your tail with justin fields
running the option for ohio state he's
unbeatable at this game but let's move
on to a team who might be looking at
justin fields in the 2021 nfl draft
that's a transition folks the chicago
bears connor you're gonna bat lead off
on this one the bears and ryan pace
may be drafting for the jobs yeah not a
lot of picks here guys but
when you get what i saw was two starters
out of a draft where you don't have a
lot of picks
that's a good job this was a solid b for
me which is
good on the ryan pay scale when you look
at some of his drafts
cole kamet a guy that is one of the he
was the best in line tight end in this
class
good red zone threat guy that can catch
a lot of passes up the seam jaylen
johnson got to make sure that shoulder
comes back in full strength but he was
one of the best press corners in this
draft and even the guys after that like
travis gibson
kendall vildor those are good
developmental players because of their
athleticism i think when you look at
somebody like vildor
he's somebody's super explosive short
area speed can play in the slot so for
the bears here
i thought they did a good job it's
always hard when you just don't have a
lot of picks you don't navigate the
board
a ton to recoup a ton of picks but
listen they needed to add a few starters
in this draft so much of this
can change with the health of jalen
johnson because if you get a full season
out of him
as a rookie he will be one of the better
corners to come
out of this draft and that's something
the bears that could take the bears
defense
over the top it's simply a huge area of
need
and listen we don't know if i mean we do
kind of know it feels like it's nick
foles's team
cole comet we don't see a ton of rookie
tight end production year after year but
he has a chance to break that mold he
can really be that middle of the field
red zone go to target so if they can get
impact of those two rookie players
while developing the pass rusher and
gibson a slot corner and vildor
i think it's a decent draft i think it's
a decent draft and i'm going to go with
a c
plus here for the bears you look at cole
commit i think this could be the travis
kelsey that matt and aggie's looking for
in this offense we know they needed some
targets to help out their quarterback
and i really like command i liked him in
the second round too they didn't have to
reach for him
the problem here is with the c pluses
they didn't have a whole lot of picks
on day one or day two they had the two
second round picks the rest of it
came on day three round five six and
seven not a lot of quality here it's not
really their fault
i like what they were able to do with
the draft but they didn't pick up a lot
of impact players
i like the two guys that we mentioned in
the second round after
that i i don't love it so i'm going c
plus not because they drafted bad but
they just they weren't in a good
position to take any good players so i
actually think it is their fault because
they trade all their
players for cleo mac obviously good
player that's why you don't have your
first rounder but
i do think they're drafting and coaching
for their jobs this year
i gave it a c and i really do like cole
comet loved him
they have about 10 tight ends that is
not an exaggeration on their roster
right now though
eventually you're gonna have to throw
the ball on the outside i did not think
they prioritized the offensive line
early enough
um sorry arlington hambright offensive
tackle from colorado in the seventh
round
ain't getting it done and they need two
starting left tackles i know you can't
fill
not two second left tackles two starting
tackles i know you can't fill every knee
to one draft class
but they got a little bit cute in my
opinion i love jaylen johnson
he is one of my favorite players in the
draft i had a round one grade on him so
as connor was saying if you get a
healthy jalen johnson
that might be your home run that might
be good enough but outside of that
they're going with this okay it's the
day three normally that's where you take
a swing
on athletes on the edges but you're not
good enough to do that
you should have taken a swing on guys on
the offensive line
and maybe even at the linebacker
position so i hope that ryan pace gets
things figured out but when you miss on
a quarterback after trading up for him
then trade for his replacement and you
also trade for cleo mac you're just
you're left with a bare cupboard and a
bad quarterback and you can't do that
and win in the nfl so i think the bears
are in a little bit of trouble i
wouldn't be surprised if they finished
fourth in this division
we are going to get to our division
picks though a little bit later
let's talk about those detroit lions a
team that last year matt stafford hurts
his back matt patricia is like
running guys out of town kwandra diggs
is going they trade darius slay in the
off season
the lions are a team that felt like they
were really in transition this off
season
then they come out and have a pretty
dang good draft connor
we have all been vocal about not being
sure this is the right duo for detroit
what did you think of this draft class
a really good draft guys and for me a
top heavy draft i think jeff akuda and
deandre
swift will be stars to come out of this
draft i think logan stenberg
at that point of the draft is a really
nice scheme fit for detroit
i'm not a believer that julian akwara
can stay healthy
that's a big concern for me but really
what it comes down to guys
is if this guy right here develops into
a top five corner in the nfl
and i think he will i think jeff akuda
is an absolute phenomenal player great
instincts
really tough physical in coverage good
long speed down the field
combined with that size so i think for
the lions here
you know i thought they could have
gotten more out of the draft but we're
gonna walk away from this one day and
say hey what did they get
if you get two stars that's an a minus
for me i think swift is the running back
this offense has
craved for so long because he's not just
the past catcher
he's not just the runner he's the
do-it-all threat that it feels like the
lions
they just never really have carry-on
johnson he's not as
explosive as a deandre swift so while i
didn't really understand somebody like
taking okora and jonah jackson as early
as they did
i liked the rest of it a lot and thought
this was a really strong draft
that could save matt patricia's job
we'll see
well yeah we will see and i'd like their
draft too i think sticking with a cuda
there was a lot of talking maybe they
move off that number three pick
and try to move down i guess there were
no callers
and that's fine i think you get the best
quarterback that i've seen
in a really long time and then there's a
lot of reports coming out of detroit
that patricia doesn't really care for a
guy
like carrion johnson so he goes out and
gets this guy the top running back on my
board
i absolutely love deandre swift and i
think that if patricia does
want to bring in some patriot style
offense deandre swift can catch the ball
out of the backfield he does it very
well
he's very shifty i think that he can
split time with carrion johnson early
before he eventually takes over that job
i really like him i like him at the top
of the second round
and i like the value i like that he's
putting a stamp on this team and saying
we're gonna run the ball we're gonna
take two offensive linemen we're gonna
run it down your throat we're gonna play
tough football in the nfc north
i'm giving this this draft an a i was
very impressed with what they did
yeah i liked this draft as well i think
it's the best one we've seen bob quinn
have since he took over that gm roll
like mellow said
coming from new england i give the lions
an a as well and you guys highlighted
jeff akuda
an incredibly special corner deandre
swift was our collective number one
running back in this draft
i really enjoyed what they did outside
the first two rounds as well
i think julian ocara has some really
nice skills if he can stay healthy
go look and see what he did to austin
jackson from ufc unless you're a miami
dolphins fan
then you're not going to want to watch
that tape but everyone else is because
the length is there the speed is there
and a frame that's still being filled
out i thought jonah jackson for ohio
state was very
underrated i think at times we looked at
wyatt davis who we're going to talk a
lot about in 2021 but
jonah jackson was holding his own as
well logan stenberg could play
swing tackle he could play inside guard
and something the trademark of both
those two players they were very
physical
run blockers so i like that the lions
went back to this and do not be
surprised by the way
if that fifth round pick quinn test if
he can play like he did at the end of
the year
he's going to be a baller at the red
zone you already got kenny galladay
who's incredibly physical now you adding
quinn tezifis i
i like that they're giving matthew
stafford some weapons hopefully we see
last year's
pick in the first round number eight
overall tj hawkinson become a little bit
more than he was
tight ends have a tough transition but i
liked this draft like i said i think
it's the best one we've seen from them
i had to give the detroit lions an a
which i
i can't ima imagine i've ever done that
my 10 years at bleacher before probably
since you drafted all those receipts i
took
oh man the matt millen jokes i should
have done today's show and overalls
it really would have brought it all
together shaved to the mustache done the
overalls
it's an r not an n miller millin
speaking of those pesky detroit lions
we've got an awesome gridiron
heights lions uh versus the joker i've
not seen this one i'm excited
[Music]
i've got some bad news we're gonna
practice in a blizzard again even though
we play inside you don't
listen do you you ask do you have any
impressive stats
all i have are stats
megatron always tells me to be like the
lion's greats and retire
early ladies and gentlemen pad stafford
what's the most reliable ford in detroit
a staff board okay i like that jokes and
i did not like that
do you want to know how i got these
scars oh you're combining jokers i've
had a broken back torn finger ligaments
my whole career i didn't know if i
existed but i do
we almost beat the cheats and other
disenfranchised cubies are starting to
notice
hello rogers oh i thought it was
something scary like the bears
good joke don't you laugh at me the
floor i used to think the lions were a
tragedy
but now i realize they're a comedy can
you introduce me as
joker no i'm mediocre can't take a joker
can you guys just let me have one thing
[Music]
now it is time to actually pick a
division
winner something we towed around a
little bit with the other
breakdowns of these divisions but we're
actually putting our stamps on it this
week
i will gladly go first so everyone can
laugh i'm picking the minnesota vikings
i know kirk cousins
has been inconsistent if we get non-big
game kirk cousins where we don't see the
turnovers
i think this vikings team is going to be
very very good i love the defense
i think mike zimmer's the best coach in
this division
and i just got a feeling that matt
lafleur and aaron rodgers probably
aren't getting along too well this
season
we'll see how that goes but i am taking
the vikings to win the nfc north in 2020
yeah i think so too and even when we
picked these in i was a little unsure
are we going with division winners this
is draft winners
it's the vikings either way i i don't
care i do think that they did enough
with this draft to improve
they're going to be in the leader spot
and i know that people look at the
vikings they look at that quarterback
but these guys win every year i mean
they beat the saints in the playoffs a
couple times
this is a good football team they just
keep getting the job done
i think they definitely do next season
i'm with you guys all the way
three across the board for the vikings
here i think when you look at this kirk
cousins he'll keep growing in that
offense i think another thing that's not
talked about enough
and you know this is no disrespect to
kevin stefanski in any way
i actually think gary kubiak taking over
the full reigns of the offense is even
an
upgrade to be completely honest with you
here i think dalvin cook will absolutely
shine once again
justin jefferson they really won't miss
a beat in their pass game at all
and i think when you look at the defense
d'neil hunter is quietly one of the best
young still young defenders in the
entire nfl
and they got two really tough corners to
play behind him now in this draft so on
top of mike hughes
being there i look at minnesota they are
locked and loaded and i think if green
bay had added a couple more impact
players this would have been a much more
interesting conversation to me
especially after the season they just
had but when you look at some of the
transition
and how these teams have handled it
minnesota is the one that's handled it
the best and i think they'll win the
division because of that
all right let's get to some draft on
draft questions first from our guy
dan dan dan i know there's been a lot of
talk about this being the year the lions
have to win to save bob quinn and matt
patricia's jobs
do you think they did enough during the
off season to do that so we talked about
that a little bit during the video
i do not personally think they've done
enough to win that i still think that
there's a team
that's probably going to finish last in
this division because
we'll see what the bears what happens
with nick foles but i don't think
they're ready to compete with the
packers or vikings guys
so i think the lions are a team that's
probably looking for a new head coach in
2021
let me just go ahead and put a name in
there for you ford family eric
the enemy go get him ooh why you gotta
do that to me matt
um now you got me flustered i don't
think that they did enough
in this offseason because i don't know
if matt stafford's healthy i think that
we might see another season where
he's either banged up again or he hasn't
recovered fully from injury
i like the lions and what they did but i
don't think it's gonna be enough to save
those jobs i think we're still looking
at a team that
maybe wins six games it's a very tough
division and i think they were kind of
hinting or at least flirting with
maybe getting rid of patricia after this
season so no
sadly if you're a matt patricia fan i
don't think he's done enough
to save his job this year i think you're
gonna be looking for hopefully a
different court uh
coach option than matthew yeah i'm gonna
be honest i'm surprised that they didn't
move on after this year to be completely
honest here
but i think after listen it's just i'm
gonna be
real it's not a very winnable division
for the detroit lions and you can old
takes expose me if they go and win 12
13 games whatever it takes but barring
some kind of
wild injury to kirk cousins or aaron
rodgers here
the packers right now just and the
vikings obviously just seem a lot better
and the bears defense is so good it's no
guarantee that the lions aren't looking
at last place in this division but
the good news for the lions fans whoever
they do hire
they are walking in with a better roster
now that it includes jeff akuda
and deandre swift and hopefully an
improved offensive line on top of that
but
it's just very hard for me to picture
long term that matt patricia's really
the guy there
wyatt charter back-to-back show
questions why a good job
if you had to bet on a day 2 pick being
a pro bowler and running backs
are excluded gentlemen so no deandre
swift no cam acres no jk dobbins
who would it be how about antoine
winfield jr tambe buccaneers safety i
think he's probably gonna play some slot
corner as well
he's gonna be the honey badger in that
defense also working with todd bowles
who knows a thing or two about the honey
badger adam in arizona also knows a
thing or two about safety's pretty good
at that position
honey badger is my guy i think that's a
really good pick antoine winfield
because he's he's a ball hawk i think
he's gonna find him his way around the
ball
and when you're looking at pro bowlers
and rookies that's what you're going to
be looking at
can he get those interceptions those
forced fumble recoveries
winfield's the guy that's kind of who i
was targeting uh i'm going to take eden
gross mados though with the carolina
panthers i think he's going to be able
to pin his ears back
and get after the quarterback i think
that he can do enough in his rookie
season this guy i thought would go in
the first round
he falls to the second round i like the
fit with the panthers i think he can be
a guy
at least to watch for as a pro bowl
maybe not a pro bowl starter
maybe one of those injury replacement
guys but i think he can be a pro boy
i'll go on the offensive side of the
ball and look at michael pittman jr for
the colts i think he's walking into a
scenario where he's getting wide
receiver two targets and he's just going
to graduate to being their top
wide receiver very similar to what
happened with michael thomas going into
new orleans i think pittman's just in a
situation where
he will thrive right away especially
with philip rivers
you know obviously forcing him the ball
at times but pittman great in the red
zone really tough in between the 20s
i feel pretty good about saying he has
the best chance to be a pro bowler out
of all the offensive players even
counting the running backs
from the second round of this draft all
right last draft on draft question thank
you all for the questions today we'll be
back tomorrow same time 5pm eastern time
get those questions ready
g martini if you had to bet today
who would your pick be for the heisman
trophy
that is a tough one because there are so
many good returning players
i want to go last this time mellow if
you let me go first i'm going to take
your guy justin fields
i like justin bieber i know you do but
uh twitter doesn't
i like justin fields a lot as well and
we're talking about college football
as a draft prospect i think maybe he's
getting a little bit more attention than
people think he should but i like what
he does on the field at ohio state i
think he's going to have another huge
season in that offense
where he can run the football he can
throw the football and he's going to get
a lot of wins
on a blue blood program that just it
equates to winning the heisman trophy
yeah i called him a dark horse heisman
trophy winner contender
last year guys when we were in vegas so
i'm double downing on that with fields
who came pretty damn close as a
youngster and i'll say this right now he
has a chance to be the best quarterback
prospect in that class i know there's
trevor lawrence
i i understand that and trevor lawrence
had his ups and downs last year too
physical talent lawrence might have more
right now but fields is in that
conversation to be a top three pick
there is no doubt in my mind
and he's playing in an offense playing
in the big ten where he's gonna put up
absolutely ridiculous numbers once again
i love his mobility
i think he has a pretty good arm i would
bet on him to win the heisman
that would make four straight transfer
quarterbacks to win the heisman trophy
if justin fields did it next year
i'm just gonna go with the favorite
trevor lawrence i also think his running
back travis ctn has a pretty good shot
to be up there as well
uh we'll see that college football is
going to be wild if and when it happens
hopefully it does
um but it will be fun i think the battle
between those two is going to be
let me throw one more name out there and
i know this is a quarterback award
i think naji harris is going to see a
lot of curious yes
derek henry type carries for the alabama
offense this year
i think that he could be a dark horse a
running back that we haven't seen win
one
probably since derrick henry i think
he's going to get a lot of touches he
could be a guy
absolutely is going to get a lot of
touches for sure right that is our show
make sure you follow us
on twitter at stick football make sure
you follow us right here in the bleacher
report app keep
updated on everything happening in the
world of college football the nfl and
the nfl draft from mello and connor
we'll see you all tomorrow right here
5 p.m eastern time in the brf
[Music]
[Music]
you